hello everyone and welcome to part one
of let's play from dust now this is a
game that you may or may not have heard
of it was made by a guy the same guy
that made out of this world and that's a
game that you may or may not have heard
of but I've heard good and bad things
about it but I've always been intrigued
by it and my brother says it's great so
I'm gonna give it a try here all right
new story oh oh yeah
if anything I like the idea of God type
games like black and white and black and
white - and this has been compared kinda
to it so I'm pretty interested about
that
and I apologize if the sound is a bit
loud in the game there literally is only
one option to change the sound and
that's a little check box that says
quiet mode and I've got that enabled so
but anyway I'll figure it out later this
is cool
I like this let's seem dangerous at all
all right
okay ah I don't know what the point was
oh that is cool I like that oh love
water physics dandies Nikita I see
puia-- Vesta right T Takata Miku mo t
taro coquitos a Nancy a keenachi a
promise of America
Risa da Cindy written Leon Xavier Tama
Kotaro Peleg our tourism atonia
sounds good to me oh yeah get that
didgeridoo
Wow this is off to a weird start but I'm
okay with weird
all right I like it I like it
whatever it is I don't even know what's
going on but I like it ha ha whoa oh
good Seema dunya Sal's gonna marry
Shekinah roko so Dan Tammy
yo aren't we all amir atashi nee Baga
very jalaja oh that's what I went
through
ok I can get it all right let's see all
right read some passage move the brass
the breadth of the breast
all right up okay whoo ah it's like a
wormy worm yeah I'm gonna get you I'm
gonna get you I would be afraid of this
thing this was this is like the worm in
penumbra oh yeah finally I get control
over it run away little humans run away
no no no cool I like it so far
oh whoa okay I don't think that's a man
I think that's a woman oh where am I oh
there it is this is weird to control
maybe that's a man I don't know I can't
tell this this distance uh-huh uh-huh
all right will do just tell me how just
tell me how okay absorb and release an
earth so if I oh oh oh that is cool Boop
oh but oh I like it
oh I like it I like it I like it nominal
phenomenal okay
all right give me some earth
okay all right a little bit little bit
little bit little bit little bit
oh absolutely love the water physics
this is great all right okay
go my little minions go run go go go
team go
I only got to get five of them there
apparently but I got all of them cuz I'm
just oh I'm so awesome
let's see Luke hey baby do
hey hey secrets under here Oh
give me all of it all of it dumb all
right
spacebar all right dance for me spacebar
there we go
I think that's a dude guy looks dude ish
up in the mouth again
hello cutscene here
you know for what I I thought this was a
pseudo indie title but if it is it's
graphics are amazing like really
top-notch sebuah duniya yang baru di
bawah Akita salmon ET la mère ubu cebu
attacks a man AHA biermaier Erica GG
sounds good to me this reminds me of an
old game called populace 3 I there were
other populace before it but especially
populace 3 just the way the world looks
and the little guys move alright yep
water physics and some more get up there
got a nice old bridge here alright
come my minions get over here move your
lazy butts huh I'm really liking the
sounds in here
okay
oh they're doing something do it hey how
about that I'm I'm amazing oh yeah look
at me go oh look at me go I'm awesome oh
that's not them doing it that's me oh me
oh just like that BAM instant survival
alright fine on me
uh-huh icon in the upper left build the
village on the second totem ahh absorb
the water alright give me give me give
me give me oh cool cool oh I'm getting
way too excited about this
ah see goodness is really cool alright
grab some earth or sand rather and then
flip flip flip flip flip flip flip flip
flip flip flip and flip flip flip yep
that's pretty cool no more oh yeah
yep yep yeah yeah yeah all right
let's get it down a little bit no yep
good enough all right now you guys can
go get it
I'll phenyl in the water slurping slurp
sploosh sploosh Oh
love it love it Boop boo boo boo boo hey
up eh yeah yeah yep global view oh that
is exactly like populous oh man if you
guys haven't heard of it go Google
populace 3 it's a very it was a very
very good game ahead of its time by
bullfrog studios I believe was the
studio name oh it's great stuff they had
other good games but I can't remember
the names of them right now oh right
there are lots of oldie but goodie games
that people forget but we're like if you
looked at it and thought of the year
that they're there you wouldn't think
that what they would be able to be made
then like magic carpet is another one of
those oldie but goodie games yeah yeah
go oh yeah build those buildings right
out of the sand
oh I'm amazing I'd worship me too whoo
uh-huh vegetation okay all right
let's see okay
sounds good to me
alright ok I'm going to pause it here
but I'm actually going to keep playing
because this is really cool I want to
find out more about this thanks so much
for watching and I will see you in part
two of let's play from dust bye bye